and I want to introduce our final
speaker Priscilla Bala who's coming up
she is the director of the mentor
network at the entrepreneurial Institute
and is going to be giving a brief talk
about some of the work that she's doing
wow what an incredible lineup of Yale is
here today so many diverse changemakers
I I let's just think again all of the
speakers and moderators for sharing so
generously of their time and energy
thank so many vibrant conversations here
on I just hope you feel as energized and
inspired as I do and I tell you my bar
for energy and inspiration is pretty
high because I have the distinct luck of
being inspired for a living given that I
work just helping Yale team succeed
right so my job is to spend a lot of my
time sort of working with some of the
most passionate and talented students in
the world and spend part of my time
working with some of the most successful
and accomplished advisors that can help
that student talent succeed in building
new things so I think I when the job is
new for me so I've been at why I now for
three and a half months I was yo college
06 I was also som 14 but it's the job of
the Yale entrepreneurial Institute which
some of you I know are familiar with but
some might not be in the Institute or
why I as we friends call it is yells
umbrella organization for
entrepreneurship and its mission is
really to just foster Yale entrepreneurs
throughout the whole University so
undergraduates and graduate students
across all of the schools right it's
dedicated to really help students test
their ideas develop them with expert
guidance and then launch new products
and services that might have a serious
impact in the world to do that the why I
which is now celebrating 10
anniversary has a number of
entrepreneurs and residents it has a
mentor network it has space at 254 Elm
Street which is very cool and you can
visit and students get to work there it
has a bunch of helper student teams that
support the the new ventures through
being a venture creation advisors or
consultants and it also has corporate
partners that provide a lot of in-kind
help for all of these students and all
of these resources are deployed
primarily in three principal programs
that Yale is doing through the why I so
the first is called a venture creation
program and what it does is it gives
early early stage teams a thousand
dollars in mentors to really try to just
test their ideas build prototypes and
figure out their market then we also
have the summer fellowship where which
is this competitive intensive boot camp
where you get fifteen thousand dollars
in grant funding a team of mentors and
ten weeks at Yale with a number of other
resources and connections to the
community to try to really get your your
venture to the next level and then we
have the why I Innovation Fund which
gives a hundred-thousand-dollar
convertible notes in pre seed funding to
promising yell startups ok now the
interest in entrepreneurship IL is
growing tremendously so in the three
months that I've been on the job should
have been this the last batch of these
the applications that we had 81 teams
from across the university applied for
our programs and that doesn't even
include all of the activity and interest
in teams that are coming from all of the
sister organizations that why I has
across the campus so if you didn't
graduate in the last three years I can
name a few new things for you like the
program and entrepreneurship at the Yale
School of Management the center for
biomedical and interventional technology
the center for business and the
environment innovate health yeah at Yale
and the center for engineering
innovation and design which is this
really cool maker space that's available
to everybody right about a quarter of
all incoming undergraduate freshman out
to Yale express an interest in business
and entrepreneur
ship which is pretty amazing if you
think about the fact that they come to
you'll generally for the liberal arts
education and the pension is not
necessarily business but that means that
now that all these students are coming
through the ecosystem for
entrepreneurship that we need to build
needs to be you know stronger than ever
and as diverse as ever right which
brings me back to to the team at theme
of today and the amazing thing about
seeing all of the diverse voices that
came through now is that even though
they were all very different one thing
that I thought was really amazing in in
the way they were explaining their
challenges how they faced them how they
overcame them and the impact that
they're having now is that at the end of
the day we are all connected and
committed even when we do different
things that are focusing on different
industries we are connected and
committed to giving equal opportunity to
talent right no matter where it comes
from or however it looks and that is
something that now we can drive as a
culture change and for that I want to
again thank all of the organizers of the
conference and yells at tech for really
exemplifying right the kind of
leadership that changes the conversation
around everything that we're trying to
accomplish so I don't know where you
guys went but if you're still around
please let's let's think the months
again if you could stand up and just be
recognized for bringing us all together
here that would be really tremendous
they're not here so my thanks oh there's
mr.
well Victor for your tireless efforts as
the the National chair VL tag all of the
regional chapters national chapters this
is really important this is really
amazing because our alumni are really
how we can grill this network and bring
the kind of expert advice that helps the
teams right I can't wait to attend
future events and I hope you feel the
same in which case everyone should go to
Yale tech org and sign up for their
newsletter so that you don't miss any of
those activities and when I think of
other ways that we can then continue to
drive this conversation in action right
look and really do our part in changing
you know what the leadership and
technology looks like or what the faces
of entrepreneurship really looked like
you know I think that it's really
important for all of us to really rally
in action and continue to help others
and when it comes to the Yale
entrepreneurial Institute and all the
venture teams that are coming out of
yield there are a few ways you can get
involved alright so the first is
mentorship which is what I do or what
I'm trying to cultivate and if you are
if you have you know eight to ten years
of operational experience as a
successful entrepreneur or as an
executive it would be really terrific
for you to consider applying for the
Yale innovation mentor network you know
expert advice is one of the most
fundamental and valuable resources that
we can offer some of those teams you
know Michaels story when he talks about
the fact that they were all a bunch of
21 22 and 23 year olds in a room is
pretty difficult for a lot of the
passionate and talented folks that we
have and and your experience can go a
long way so if you're interested or if
you know someone that could be a great
addition to the network please do come
talk to me right corporate partnerships
also provide incredible and significant
pro bone or resources to a number of
those teams that get now access to
expert services and advice in a way that
they couldn't otherwise afford given how
early they are in their development so
we really appreciate all those
relationships and connections funding
right we've all talked about pitching
and venture capital and so forth so if
you're an investor if you have
investment connections being able to
point the teams that
out to sources of funding and
development resources is really really
valuable funding for Yale really helps
us also sort of expand the programs and
build new ways to encourage and and
support entrepreneurship around the
campus so we thank you for your
generosity and lastly one other thing
the why is partnering with the office of
career strategy to to do this program
called the why I summer innovation
internship when in the idea there is to
really get startups and entrepreneurial
II minded firms to get a pathway to hire
motivated and talented Yale students
that are interested in like Michael was
saying less traditional career paths
that go beyond sort of consulting and
finance and now a lot of people that are
thinking a lot more about technology
business development marketing venture
capital and so forth so if you're an
employer interested in that let's also
let's also talk about that so I wanted
to help I wanted to think once again
also the corporate sponsors for this
event and Morrison Foerster for
therefore for their hospitality and
opening their doors to us today McCauley
and associates instacart thunder thank
you so much all for your crucial support
and now I know that I stand between you
and drinks so let me do so no longer and
let me just say that let's take all of
the inspiration from these conversations
today to really work together to change
the face of tech and continue this
conversation upstairs so if you want to
join us for the happy hour you can just
go down the hall and up the stairs and
we'll be able to to celebrate
entrepreneurship around Yale in and all
that we do until later tonight so thank
you so much and enjoy the rest of the
evening
you